so our next speaker um
really loves to cook read books
and meditate so hopefully this year has
been
very good for him he's had plenty of
time to do all that
please welcome michael all right thank
you so much
and thank you jared and thank you also
to everyone at the blender analytics
team
for having me here today hello everyone
my name is mike tudu i'm an economist at
the bureau of labor statistics office of
productivity and technology
today i'll be talking with you about my
experience in creating
a a function in r that does the term
quest index
so the torn quest index is a is a method
of aggregating index measures together
for the purposes of analysis
and reporting for official statistics
and just to
let everyone know any views expressed by
me in this presentation is
my own and not of the agency so the
motivation for this project was to
provide a set of functions to help
individuals to properly aggregate
indices
using the turncourse method in r if in
case any staff wanted to use r for
or for production
so before we get to that i wanted to
cover some national accounts
economic vocabulary so we have a uh
so we have a good understanding for the
rest of the presentation
of what i'm going to be talking about so
here's a list of some of the
terms i'm going to be covering really
quickly
so the first term is productivity so
that's a measure of efficiency which
compares the amount of goods and
services produced
with the amount of inputs used
so we have labor productivity so that's
the efficiency at which
labor hours are utilized in producing
output for goods and services
typically typically called output per
hours
uh hours hours of labor then there's
also multi-factor productivity also
known as total factor productivity
is the efficiency at which measured
inputs
are utilized in producing outputs of
goods and services
next and you'll hear me say this a lot
is the nayx
or also meaning the north american
industry classification system
this is a standard used by federal
statistical agencies in classifying
business establishments
then there's the cost of production so
this is the cost incurred by
a business for providing a product or
providing a service then the word
measures so this is a numerical value
that represents an
aspect size scale or growth examples
include measures of productivity
measures of output
etc next year's the word index
so this is statistical representation of
a level over time
for a particular measure using a base
year
next is the price index so this is a
measurement of prices
movements in numerical series and the
quantity index
it represents a real measure of a
particular output or input
and at the bottom we see like a a
calculation here for costs and prices
which are
talk about towards the end of the
presentation
all right so now i recovered some
productivity vocabulary
let's go over the agenda for today so
first i'm going to
provide some context to use the torn
course index
method by providing you information
about productivity measures
and then cover some common index
formulas that's used for
official economic statistics afterwards
i'll cover how to use the total cost
index using excel example
and then i'll show how i did it in r
all right so let's do a quick overview
of some productivity measures
so why is productivity important well
here's some reasons why
policymakers use it to help determine
living standards it's a source
of gain it's also indicative gains of
national income
it's a key indicator for competitiveness
across industries and nations
it's also used in employment projections
as well
so here are the some of the news
releases
that my officers produce on an annual
and quarterly basis we have quarter
labor productivity
and also put out an annual measure and
there's also
the annual multi-factor productivity
and is at the major sector level
and there's also uh multi-factor
productivity and labor productivity at
the four to five digit next industry
levels as well
okay so we just cover some of our our
data products what we use it for
let's talk about some common index
formulas
so um so an index number is uh
the economic data of figuring reflecting
the price and quantity compared
with the standard or base value so the
base value typically equals 100 or one
at the index number and it's usually
expressed a hundred times
the ratio of the base value for example
if a commodity
costs twice as much as 1970 as it did in
1960
its index number would be 200 relative
to 1960.
so economics index numbers are generally
are the time series data summarizing
movements in a group of
related variables so a good example of
an index series that's used is the
consumer price index
right so let's here
just providing you some additional
illustration about the
economic how it's how we use these index
measures
we have the economic circular flow
diagram you may have
remembered this from econ 101 here we
see the classical
flows diagram which represents the
organizations within an economy
households firms and markets and markets
that produce
factors of production let's say raw
materials energy other services
at each stage of the flow diagram their
economic activity
is measured
and so we see here
there's different index formulas that's
used to measure these kinds of
activities
as a slide before we see the consumer
price index we see
labor multi-factor productivity producer
price index other things
but then here we have the different
index formulas we have those spares
in a couple different spots and also
posh is also used but also the turquoise
index is
another measure another formula that's
used in different spots to measure the
economy
all right so here's a quick illustration
of these formulas so the spares
is just uh we let's just shows
um answers the question how much would a
set of basket of goods from a base
period cost today
in posh we have this the posh equation
you see at the bottom answers the
question what is the difference in
in the price of today's house in today's
dollars versus the price
of the same house in a base year's
dollars
next we have the fisher index so this
helps answer the question what is the
unbiased value of today's homes
being constructed in constant dollars so
here in doing this it attempts to
eliminate two kinds of problems
associated
with the previous two indexes the
tendencies to overstate
inflation with lespers and the tendency
to understate
inflation with posh so the fissure takes
geometric meaning of those two measures
in order to to do that
all right so next is the turnquest so we
have
the term cross index and also the
fissures that actually comes up with
very similar values
these are also called superlative
indices that produce similar results
and are generally favored formulas for
calculating price indexes
all right so now i just want to go over
a quick example here in excel
so just covering the term course index
so
just to give you a little bit more
information the term course index is a
weighted geometric mean of the price
relative to athletic averages of value
shares
in the two periods using the two pairs
as weights
so here in this example i
am wanting i want to aggregate
different assets here in this example
i want to aggregate computers
communication equipment and other
equipment
into uh one uh top line measure called
information capital and i'm doing this
all for one
next industry sector so what i'm going
to need
is the those assets within that
particular
industry of their quantity index
so i have that at the very top of the of
the graph that we
of the slide you see here and towards
the bottom
the second we see the log change and
this right
um that section we're actually
calculating
the the two-year rate of change of the
quantity index
because that's part which is part of the
formula then at the very bottom
for the weights i'm going to be using
the current dollar
production cost for each of those assets
so the first step in constructing the
weights because we want to use the
the average cost shares we want to get
the total
of each of these assets and we see the
total at the very bottom
next we want to calculate um
using the cost we want to just do a
check to make sure that we're doing the
calculations right making sure
everything sums up to
100 and then what we're going to do is
once we get the shares of each of those
assets
we're going to calculate the average
share so there's going to be two year
average shares which you see at the very
bottom of the chart
the next step is to calculate the two
period average shares to the log
change so here this is uh um
in this calculation we're actually
coming up with each assets contribution
to the aggregate number so we have
computers communications equipment and
other equipment other equipment being
i'll say fax machines and different
things like that for a particular
industry
so once we calculate that we have each
of their contributions
and at the bottom we sum all those
contributions
up of those three different assets to
get information capital
and then what we do next is we want to
to have this numerical value in the
presentation form we want to
normalize it first by using the
commutative product and next we want to
index it by the base year so the base
year in this example
is 2009.
all right so we went over some common
common index formulas and then we also
went over an example of how we could
actually calculate the total course
index in excel so excel shows a good way
of breaking it down into more grammar
information so you could
have a better understanding about how to
go about doing that
so how and why why do we use this
so um there's literature on the theory
of index numbers so the turncourse index
has desirable
desirable properties is less prone to
outliers
and different things like that and it's
also used in a lot of uh
um different different statistical
agencies
as because it's not impact as impacted
by outliers
all right so i just went over that
okay so now let's talk about how to do
it in r
so i'm going to show a demonstration
with the example i just shown in excel
i'm going to be aggregating three assets
from a particular industry
to form the information capital measure
using computers communications equipment
and also others being fax machines and
different
types of technology equipment
so yeah so in this exercise here
or in this project i found that these
two
packages helped out a lot to create
the set of functions that i had had
created
to perform this task calculate the term
course index
so we have d ply r and then tidy r
so dplyr is a package which provides a
set of tools for
efficiently manipulating data sets in r
dplyr focuses on
data frames the player is also
faster and easier to use it provides a
consistent set of tools that helps us
solve most common problems tidyr
is helps us tighten the data and it's
easy to
to munch with dplyr and other packages
in the tidy universe
some of the main functions in teddy are
are the pivoting of tables
and converting between long and wide
formats
and so here's the main function for each
of the packages that i use
for for this project so on the left
for dplyr we have the mutate select the
range group by rename
and the different joins and tidyr i
primarily use the gather function
because i needed help
transposing the data into a usable
format
so these are some of the tasks that was
done by those functions so mutate i used
it to create new variables
select used to select certain variables
pick certain variables for subsequent
steps
arrange sorting the data group by
grouping it and then the joins merging
the tables
i just talked about transposing
yeah and so here's um some additional
information about how
the basic format of those functions how
it's used
and yeah if you have the pipe operator
you could actually skip over
um the argument where you need to put in
the data frame
but typically it's the data frame and
then you have the arguments on on the
far right
and here for tight er this is just an
example of how i was using it using
gather function
just transposing it and to get into a
usable
getting the data frame into a usable
format for subsequent calculations
and combining tables
okay so like i had mentioned before the
exercise
information capital we want to aggregate
the other
yeah it could be some medical equipment
fax machines different things like
computers communications you want to
form the information capital
measure and this is the task and at the
very bottom is actually the
the functions name that i created um and
i have a
a link to share with everyone if in case
you want to look at the code
so it's time quest underscore index
underscore m just for this example and
we see on the right we see the arguments
that i have there
all right so here's the data in its
original format before
well actually after i have imported it
into r and um this is what it initially
looks like
and if for those of you are interested
want to download the data from the link
that i have
um you still get in this this kind of
format but
in this is how it looks so on the far
right we have
the cost different cost measures where
you have the underscore c
suffix we have the sect in the far right
so that's the
next industry and then the far left we
have the year because we this is the
time series data
and the computers communications and
others on the left side
that is the quantity index measures
so before we get into the main function
uh
there's some pre-processing that's
needed so what i needed to do in this
section here i needed to separate out
after importing it into our putting into
um into the objects uh df underscore
cost for the cost measures
and df underscore qty for the quantity
index measures
so that would be used in later steps
for um so we just start combining tables
all right so this is the main function
of of this uh
for the to do the tornquist index for
this exercise
now i'm gonna go over it um bit by bit
so it's not just gonna
work off this light here
all right so we just um have a
superimposed a little bit so we have at
the very top there's some formatting
that's done
but so i'll just go over block one so
i'm just covering it in different blocks
so in block one we have
after we have imported it and we've
called in the function
we had sorted into the different objects
what we're going to do we're going to
transpose both cost and quantity indexes
into a usable format so it could be
combined for
subsequent calculations next as you see
going down a little bit more at the
inner joint we're combining both
quantity and indexes
and we're combining it by the in the
next industry sector
which is labeled as sector and also by
the assets computer
communications and others which is
labeled as ems
and next we also combining it by the key
is also gear
so we see with the buy is that those are
the key
those are the key variables there then
we're going to sort it
and next we're going to actually
construct the aggregate cost
for the very um for that next step
because that's
following on we need to calculate just
like
we did in the excel example the average
cost shares for the weights
all right so in this section here
calculating the average cost shares for
each of the asset components
uh for yeah computers communication
equipment
others and we also calculate the rate of
change
and you can see where you see the log
difference towards the middle of the
screen
and once we are so once we perform those
calculations
we um select those variables again for
subsequent uh
for subsequent processing so um after
we've calculated the average cost shares
and we multiply that to the rate of
change of the quantity index and we get
our contributions for each of the
different assets computers
communications equipment
and others which is labeled here as
the the object product
all right so in this step here once we
have performed this test before we
we sum up all of the different
contributions for each of the assets
to get our value for information capital
this is
the um which is the goal that we're
trying to achieve here
and then once we do that we want to
normalize the data by performing the
cumulative product
and we see that in the middle section of
the slides here
and once we do that we're going to index
this value
to get a quantity index by and using the
base year of 2009
then towards the bottom here we're
we're calculating some additional
measures for
for this exercise which is once we have
the quantity index we could also
come up with the price index as well
because we already have cost
that was done in the very beginning part
of the program
and so this slide here is showing um
the before and after picture so before
on the far left we have our data that we
imported into r
for the different asset components we
have computers communications and others
and we also have the quantity index and
the cost uh for the
particular industry sector and in the
far right we have the final product of
this after we've performed this exercise
the information capital
measure so we just aggregated uh those
three
assets into the one information capital
which would be used later on for
reporting purposes or possibly analysis
okay so i just showed a short
demonstration with that
and just a review i think i'm getting
close to time here
we went over the different productivity
measures
and um we also covered the common index
formulas that's out there and it's used
i talked about how um term quest is used
and why it's important
um why a lot of people tend to use
turncourse index
and then it performed a short
demonstration on well both how to do it
in excel
and also how you can do it in r
and uh yeah here's a link to my code but
i'm not sure we have time for questions
but
um
and here's the link to code i could post
that into chat as soon as i'm
done over here and if you have any
additional questions
my contact information is here and
please stop by our website at
www.bls.gov backslash mfp to check out
all the all of our other data products
that we have available
great thank you very much it's wonderful
having that talk thank you
thank you very much for that so our next
speaker